[Musique]
ces métiers intention sont en général
dans la restauration mais aussi dans le
BTP cela veut dire les maçons les
peintres les monigers mais aussi les les
ceux qui font les manœuvres dans la
logistique également donc on a besoin
dans la logistique aujourd'hui mais
aussi la propreté fait partie des
métiers en
[Musique]
tension faciliter la régularisation de
ces gens qui occupent déjà les métiers
ils sont déjà en poste donc ils
travaillent euh ils sont en poste il
cotisent donc il faut les régulariser
aujourd'hui faire l'article c'est que
les patrons ne seront plus là à être les
les les véritables euh moteurs pour
régulariser parce qu'il y a les SERFA
les promesses d'ambos qu'il fallait
remplir par les par les patrons donc une
fois que ça passe cela veut dire que la
régularisation ne va plus dépendre des
patron il y a une contradiction en en
sur la question de supprimer l'ame pour
établir euh l'aide médicale d'urgence il
y a une contradiction si c'est pour des
questions économique c'est que c'est
contradictoire parce que au lieu de
soigner euh le travailleur sans papier
ou le sans papier tout court à à un tau
de 2 € il faut attendre que ça soit
urgent pour le payer des soins qui vaut
200 à 500 € donc il y a une
contradiction cette galère cette boule
au ventre ça ça ne s'arrête jamais parce
qu'au renouvellement on demande
l'autorisation de travail ça doit faire
ça doit être faite par le patron qui
doit envoyer à la plateforme service
mdœuvre étrangère sauf que ça prend du
temps et on ce qu' ce qu'on voit c'est
que les gens deviennent sans papi parce
qu'ils n'ont pas eu l'autorisation de
travail faite par le patron pourquoi
parce que certaines boîtes euh ne ne
cotise pas à l'irsf les autres c'est les
problèmes des rendez-vous on narrive pas
à avoir les rendez-vous c'est saturé
voilà ce que vit
vraiment les travailleurs étrangers que
ce soit sans papier et les travailleurs
déjà
[Musique]
régularisés